pas d'accord j'aimerais citer simplement
Gérard col et je
suis luiême disait on vit aujourd'hui
côte à côte demain on vira face à
face la France des Moulou Rachid si
geréral avait dit ça ça aurait fait un
to non seulement non seulement c'est
raciste parce que ça sépare de faites
les arabes ne sont pas arabes ça
sous-entend aussi que ceux qui posent
des problèmes sont toujours les Arabes
c'est lui qui le dit c'est une stratégie
complètement contreproductive et non
seulement ne fonctionne pas mais surtout
elle produit l'effet inverse ça rend le
rassemblement national sympathique et
pourquoi au lieu de d'attaquer de
mépriser le RN vous ne les combattez pas
sur des idées pourquoi vous êtes obligé
d' jeis désolé la France la France des
moulous des Rachid moi je vous dis moi
j'accepte pas ça vous don on aurait dit
même tu imagines gars on aurait dit la
France des mochés des David non mais
franchement imagin ou pas non mais
franchement les gars imaginez 2 minutes
et géradine tu entends ça à l'Assemblée
nationale non mais c'est une sortie imag
il dit la France des mochés des David
demain mais c'est les mecs les mec on va
dire mais les garmanin a bien parlé
aussi des desécler ou
autrespp voilà non mais simplement sur
la question des idées moi sur le
rassemblement national je bien aller
allz quand quand le rassemblement
national dit on veut préserver notre
économie de la concurrence et que au
Parlement européen ça vote contre la
taxe carbone qui est un dumping
environnemental et un dumping économique
mais là on est tout à fait à côté du
sujet et là on est sur une opposition
politique respectable là on n'est pas
sur de la haine on n pas sur de l'anathè
on n pas sur la division on on est sur
la démocratie et des oppositions
divergentes madame givern ça la
démocratie chômage vous avez voté contre
aussi les 750 milliards de l'Europe pour
le plan de relance également désolé des
SOR
commeé oppos ce so France inflammable
que l'on vit la portée de ces propos ces
propos sont dangereux voilà ils attisent
la haine entre les communautés entre les
Français nous rassemblement national ne
vous en déplais on ne voit que des
Français voilà il y a pas de couleur de
peau il y a que trois couleurs le bleu
le blanc et le rouge c'est tout VO et
pour et pour vous répondre et pour et
pour et pour vous répondre et pour vous
répondre les seuls naz les seuls nazons
olganet à l'Assemblée nationale ce sont
vos amis et c'est notamment monsieur
roberot qui a fait un salut nazi le seul
député qui a fait un salut nazi dans
l'hémicycle c'est un député macroniste
c'est Monsieur roberot c'est l'ami de
Monsieur Dupont
Moretti et concernant Gill Verdez parce
que tout à l'heure qui était finalement
sur cette thè de la France rurale de la
France rurale blanche catholique voilà
comme si c'était d'ailleurs infamment
d'être blanc et catholique et ensuite de
l'opposer à la France des quartiers vous
savez que dans notre électorat dans nos
13 millions d'électeurs on a énormément
de Français issus de l'immigration qui
vivent dans les quartier et qui
souffrent de l'insécurité et qui en ont
ralbol et qui ont envie d'être français
et qui ont envie d'élever leurs enfants
en France et nous la France vous savez
la France des Ibrahim et des Karim c'est
aussi la France de Mayot c'est celle
qu'on défend qui envie de rester
française qui envie d'avoir accès
potable qui a été abandonné depuis des
années par ce gouvernement et par ce
ministre qui ne fait rien contre la
submersion migratoire et il se tourne
vers Marine Le Pen qui est la seule à
leur parler qui est la seule à parler à
des maoraais qui sont encore une fois
des Français apparentièr et qui sont
traités comme des souscitoyens par ce
gouvernement voilà ce que je dis nous
encore une fois on appelle au
rassemblement quels que soient les
origines quels que soient les les les
religions quels que soient les tendances
les Français ont besoin d'unité or
aujourd'hui avec ces propos là bah c'est
la division et la fracturation
l'héritage que vous avez ne peut pas
vous permettre
de vont gagner au prochaines élections
parant ils étaient déjà premers aux
européennesit so une opposition au
rendez-vous avec des arguments est-ce
que vous trouvez que dupti a les bons
mots a les bons arguments dit à Marine
Le Pen ou est-ce que c'est pas des
arguments de
1982 non
mais le TPMP 90 qu'on va faire le 19
décembre pour venir faire mais sans
rigoler mettre une perruque et nous
faire et nous dire des choses qu'on a
entendu il y a 30 ans est-ce que Éric
Dupont Moretti n'est pas en accord avec
son temps mais je pense que il faut
surtout en fait c'est un du mémori non
mais c'est je le connais alors je le
connais parce que je le croise
régulièrement mais effectivement je suis
pas je suis pas la commission des lois
dont je
travaille est sympem national oui il il
est sympa il fa un peu bourru mais moi
je l'aime bien très sincère un peu
bourru ouais et puis en plus
non mais un peu bourrin il va vous
attaquer porter PL il va porter PL ça
c'est pass il il va porter
plainte non mais si on revient sur la
question du rassemblement national je
crois qu'il a aussi un aspect un peu
mémoriel on a tendance à oublier très
vite et et je crois que peut-être il
faut faire évoluer les méthodes très
bien
onend on va faire les méthodes mais je
crois qu'il ne faut pas aussi oublier de
dénoncer ce qui a pu être et de dénoncer
les discours on va écouter quelqu'un de
la génération d' Duti Daniel vas-y mais
excusez-moi moi je voudrais côé moderne
vas-y bébé mais je voudrais revenir à
pourquoi enfin le pourquoi de cette
sortie d'Éric Dupont Moretti c'est une
question d'une députée deassem
nationelle qui demandait pour sa manière
de sa solution pour qu'il ait plus
jamais Thomas la mort de Thomas ça c'est
ce qui intéresse les Français et à quoi
il a répondu quoi il a parlé du du
rassemblement national comme il aurait
parlé du Front national on a raison on
est dans les années 80 et il n'a pas
c'est pourquoi pour ne pas répondre à
cette question et c'est ça qui intéresse
les Français pourquoi le le celui qui a
porté le coup fatal à à Thomas avait
interdiction depuis pendant 2 ans de pas
porter de couteau ah il en a pas porté
un il en il est arrivé avec deux
couteaux ça voilà il a pas répondu
concrètement et en revanche il a il a
fait une sortie sur le rassemblement
national c'est scandaleux c'est c'est
pas les Français c'est pas Marine Le Pen
qui devrait porter plainte c'est c'est
tous les Français parce que cette
réponse elle a apporté quoi par parce
que vous pensez que demain le
rassemblement national au pouvoir il y
en aura pas encore des problèmes comme
ça problèm rtional
[Musique]
ce c'est ce qui préoccupe les gens de
CRP et
de non mais arrê il faut arrêter avec ça
tu t'es pas échauffé MAM vas-y molo mais
non mais l' du PTI ça devrait être les
délinquants ça devrait pas être le
rassemblement national excusez-moi on en
a marre de ça parce qu' chaque fois
d'accord
excusez-moi qu- qui préoccupe les
Français vous croyez que c'est ça
on sait pas si elle sera là en 2027 donc
tu t'en fous mais non mais on sait pas
si elle sera encore
là l'objectif c'est de prendre en compte
de prendre en compte tous les crimes les
traf stéfiant ils sont pris ils sont ils
sont pris en compte et c'est le point
évidment après politiquement on a un
adversaire politique on a plusieurs
adversaires politiques d'ailleurs donc
il faut il faut pouvoir leur répondre
aussi et je suis désolé
faond arrête enlè t
électres mais ça n'était pas la question
il nous a fait comme c'est quoi cette B
décou la politique en 2014 je je suis
ingénieur en aéronautique si voilà ouais
donc pendant 10 ans j'ai exercé en
Nouvelle-Zélande et puis j'aiétais une
immigré en Nouvelle-Zélande a oua
maintenant vous venez de parler du pont
morti
elle était tranquille en
Nouvelle-Zélande dans un avion elle se
retrouve à parler d'Eric du pont morti
le défendre sur un plateau c'est quand
même fou ça bon alors alors vous allez
porter plainte donc ça y est oui s ouais
por plainte pour justement au nom de nos
13 millions d'électeurs parce que
derrière nous nous on a un peu le cuir
ép on est habitué à ces sorties mais nos
électeurs eux ils n'y sont pas habitués
et de se voir insulter de de la sorte de
se voir traiter de naz de fasciste ils
en ont ralbol pas les qui ont été trait
de
naésent faire un petit peu de ménage
c'est pas les électeurs dans R c'est
quoi
uneis dans l'appareil des est-ce qu'il y
a des gudards est-ce que ça existe enc
par exemple complément d'enquête qui
passe
demain ils disent que je fréquente que
des voyou non mais c'est vrai voilà
est-ce que vous aussi des loubars he il
faut porter plainte ouais bah oui pas
mais il y en a qui ont l'air bien sous
tout rapport Jordan Bardella c'est le
gendre idéal parfait SP derre fois la
muscu du coup mais moi je m' je m'en
méfie et et vraiment en fait faut aller
regarder l'entourage dis-moi qui te
vous avez des nom
elle a raison géraline parce que c'est
facile de dire moi aussi on peut dire
ouais je t'ai vu avec est-ce que tu l'IS
vu avec des gens chelous moi par exemple
ici je vais vous parler de mon cas
personnel moi ici pendant toute la crise
du covid j'étais la du
gouvernement j'étais pro Macron c'était
immonde mon Dieu tu es Macron tu es
Macron tu es Macron et maintenant je
suis la grosse raciste la grosse facho
donc les étiquettes en fait moi j'étais
moi il y a encore 2 ans j'étais le
meilleur ami du Jean-Luc Mélenchon on
all
ensemble moi je vais devenir la
meilleure amie d'Éric du pourmti vous
m'inviterez plus ils sont quoi ils sont
islamophobes ils sont antisémites ils
sont quoi en fait ils sont xénophobes
c'est quoi en fait le rassemblement oui
alors la question non non non non non
c'est c'est c'est c'est des valeurs qui
sont portées et le ménage n'a pas été
fait moi je suis d'accord avec le ménage
et la question de l'entourage le maire
de Fréjus David rachelin effectivement
sur des pratiques qui ont été dénoncées
dans un livre qui s'appelle les les
rapaces me semble-t-il je crois qu'il
faut quand même mettre en avant ce que
c'est que la gestion et la gouvernance
du rassemblement
national prélu au premier tour après et
puis ERC DUP Moretti ERC Dupon Moretti
c'est sûr et certain je voà vous le dis
les 20h 14 la prochaine intervention
qu'il va faire il va parler de moi c'est
sûr et certain je connais à chaque fois
il va être invité dans c tou là ou bien
chez les autres bouffons là de de TMC il
va me mettre une car vous allez voir
merci junorou à tout de suite merci